we welcome you to cbs this morning on
this monday yeah and we begin with
troubling signs about america's progress
against the coronavirus as
covet infection rates surge now in every
state
experts say the upward trend is being
fueled by the delta variant
and by unvaccinated americans as of last
week
more than 97 percent of people admitted
to the hospital for covid
had not gotten the vaccine oh boy in the
new projections show that coveted cases
nationwide will likely continue to rise
over the next few months
peaking in mid-october daily deaths
could more than triple from current
levels
rising back up to around 850 a day
our lead national correspondent david
begno's in jackson mississippi
the state with the lowest vaccination
rate in the country david these numbers
are so scary
now i know you visited saint dominic
jackson memorial hospital
what did you learn there
gail is like deja vu all over again they
just canceled all visitation for covet
patients and they've gone back to those
face time visits let me set the scene
for you the first week of may here at st
dominic's they had two covet patients
the first week of june they had five
first week of july they had ten they've
got 59
this morning and they're looking at
extra wings of the hospital to try and
find space to house these people
here are some of their stories
this is william ball alicia is his wife
how badly has coveted ravaged his body
extremely bad he is 52 no longer
infectious
but he's too sick to go home he had a
heart attack at the end of june
and then contracted covet nine days
later there will be people who watch
this who don't think the virus is
serious
we didn't either at first i'm not gonna
lie
we had no idea she got vaccinated
he didn't they both got sick but only he
wound up like this
vicki mcknight is 64. she says her
doctor told her
not to get the covet vaccine because
she's allergic to the flu vaccine
she says a second doctor told her you
need to get the vaccine
but before she could she says she
contracted covid
at a funeral your husband got the
vaccine yes
and your husband also got covered yes
but did he end up in the hospital
no edward clifton is 38.
when he showed up sick with covet at the
hospital he didn't even know
that he had underlying conditions kidney
failure
and diabetes he too is unvaccinated
well i want to tell everybody
please take the shot this virus is
no joke if you want to feel really
really horrible
this is a great way to do it trust me 45
year old larry smoke
is also a diabetic and he had a heart
attack four years ago
he says a week after he got his first
pfizer shot
he started showing symptoms for covet
19. even people that got
both doses if they have underlying
conditions they we don't know if they
got a full antibody response
so their immune system may be weakened
so
it's making us even come back in
questions should we be given booster
doses now
to those with underlying medical
conditions back in william ball's room
a doctor was called to determine if
william was having another heart attack
his wife spoke for it he will get the
vaccine when he gets out of the hospital
when he said i want that back tell me
what you're thinking
he's got to get out of the hospital
first
within the last week we've let you hear
from kobe patients in arkansas louisiana
and now mississippi and i often hear
from folks on social media who say
david i don't want them forcing the
vaccine on me just give me the facts
so here are the facts from mississippi
89 percent of people hospitalized here
are unvaccinated
91 of covet patients who've died in
mississippi
are unvaccinated those are the facts
gail and those are the facts we need to
hear over and over and over again david
thank you very much